Hey, Vsauce Michael here, and today
we are going to be talking about the past.
But not like history—in fact—we will
be talking about what we call now.
This very newest moment in time,
and the fact that we can
never really be aware of or live
in what we call now,
because it takes time for our brain
to process the information about
what's happening now,
and it takes time for that information
to get from the rest of our body
to our brain.
In fact, the taller you are,
the further back from now, the further
back from the past you live.
But more importantly, why do we call
emotional, relationship-based movies
targeted at females
chick flicks?
Well, for the answers to these questions,
we're going to start with the
flash lag effect.
David Eagleman has done some amazing
research on this effect.
It's what occurs when a participant looks
at a ring moving around in a circle.
A light is flashing exactly in the middle
of the ring.
This is exactly what the photons landing
on their retinas represent.
But when asked what they saw, participants
responded they saw this.
Now, for the longest time, it was
hypothesized that people said this
because our brains guess ahead.
Our brain assumed that the ring
would continue doing what it had been doing,
and figured it would be safer to go ahead
and say that the ring was already
a bit ahead of the light.
But Eagleman wanted to know what
would happen if
when that flash of light occurred in
the middle of the ring,
the ring all of a sudden reversed direction
and spun around the other way.
If our brains really are guessing ahead,
participants should still say
that they saw this,
because the brain figured that the ring
would be there and were surprised
when it went the other direction.
But instead, participants
said that they saw this.
Now, how could they have seen this
if they had no way of knowing
that the ring was going to reverse direction?
Were their brains clairvoyant?
Can our brains see into the future?
As it turns out, no.
What's really happening here is that
our eyeballs are receiving an image—
an image of a flash of light
inside a ring.
But then our brains wait a little bit
to make sure that we have the full story.
And as the ring begins to reverse direction,
that new information is incorporated
into what we actually sense,
and we become aware of the wrong
version of now.
By doing more studies with
rings traveling at different speeds,
Eagleman was able to determine
that what we are aware of as now,
what our brain tells us is happening
actually happened 80 milliseconds
in the past!
Now, 80 milliseconds is not a lot of time,
but it's a little scary to think that
our brain has no
physical way of knowing, being aware of,
or even living anywhere
but slightly in the past.
Nerve impulses travel through our body
at a top speed of around 250 miles per hour.
But now, look at Bill Warner
on a motorcycle.
He's going really fast.
In fact, he's going 278 miles per hour,
which means that this guy on a motorcycle
is traveling faster than my brain
can even figure
out what now is.
Keep in mind that 250 miles per hour
is the top speed
for neural impulses within our body.
If I tap my nose and tap my toes
at the exact same time,
it feels instantaneous,
even though there is no physical way
that the brain could actually be receiving that,
because when I tap my nose,
the message goes right into my brain.
But when I tap my toes, the message
has to travel across the entire length of my body.
The brain waits momentarily to make sure that there's nothing else going on or coming in,
and then corroborates all that information
and we become aware that the taps were
indeed instantaneous.
But we don't become aware of that tap
until the brain is sure,
which means that the taller you are,
the longer the brain has to wait
for that physical message to come from your toes,
the further behind you technically are
in actually feeling the touch—
the further back in the past you're living.
When there's a delay like that between
sensory information or brain processing,
we become used to that delay and begin
to just see them as instantaneous events,
which leads to some weird behavior.
If participants are pushing a button
that causes a light to flash with a delay
between the two actions of about 80 milliseconds,
they will learn that it's instantaneous.
But if the researchers shorten that distance
so that now when the button is pushed, the light
flashes in only—let's say—
40 milliseconds, the participants,
even though they are actually causing the light to come on
will deny it and they'll say,
"No way! That came on before I pushed the button!
I didn't do it!"
That was also a flash of light.
But light bulbs don't receive a continuous
direct stream of electricity through the wire.
Instead, they receive alternating current
in most businesses and households.
So the filament is actually being excited
and left alone about 50 to 60 times a second.
But our eyeballs don't notice any flicker for a few reasons.
One, it's happening really fast, but
mainly because that filament
continues to be super hot during
that little gap in time.
The only way to really see this flicker is to use a high frame rate camera
when a light bulb is being turned
on or off so it's cooler.
There's the flicker.
You know what else flickers?
A film projector.
It's easy to think that a film projector works
merely because a roll of film
is dragged across a light source, but if that were the case,
a movie screen would be a blur of fast moving images.
Instead, a shudder is used.
The shudder opens and closes
to let an image hit the screen, and then when shut,
the next image comes into place and it
opens and puts that on the screen.
Now, early films were shot at only about
16 frames per second.
So sitting in the theater, you would see a bright image
flashed 16 times on the screen, which was not fast enough to not be noticeable.
So, movies flickered,
which is why they were called flicks, which is where
we get the word chick flick.
All right, I'm gonna go now.
And of course, by now, I mean I will leave
80 milliseconds before you
become aware that I've left.
I put three links to previous
Vsauce videos in the description
that are related to this one if you
haven't seen them yet.
One is about why time feels
like it's going faster as we get older.
Another is about the frame rate
of the eyeball,
and the other is about the stopped
clock illusion.
Have fun, and as always,
thanks for watching.